hey you guys Saturday yeah we did that
show last night is about poultry guys
I was pretty loaded on the second half
was I making sense yeah you saw it was
fine okay well yeah cuz I edited it
earlier today yeah um you know we were
both pretty messed up at the end well
because what ends up happening is that
we don't really start recording we
started recording them on Friday nights
and we don't really start recording
until like seven ish yes and then you
know we get a big drink going and then
like we record like the first half or
whatever and that usually takes like an
hour hour and a half whatever and then
we take a break in between likes we can
upload [ __ ] and then it's like so we
didn't end up finishing until almost
midnight right it's ridiculous yeah and
then I was like trying to I didn't
realize it was that late when we got
well the show ended up being three hours
so like a little over three hours they
liked it but you know I mean you're
you're burning it up Jenny you're
[ __ ] burning it up if we could have
made two shows out of that geez well
we're gonna talk about five cases yeah I
mean that's like it was just two because
I was afraid that the one case it this
happens alive we talk about like
paranormal stuff I always kind of feel
like there's not enough content there to
like make a long show man but she's got
me with her she forgets that yeah that's
because I'm adding to that [ __ ] yeah I
just don't I just like have a paranoia
about like running out of [ __ ] to talk
about and they were just sitting there
going um although I don't think that's
ever happened it's like it's hilarious
to me now to think that you know back
when we first started the show we were
very adamant about keeping it to an hour
yeah you know what I mean so some of the
shows were only like fifty three minutes
or something like that which is amazing
I'm like how the [ __ ] did we do that we
were moving right along I guess and we
only took one wheel in took one topic at
a time and we didn't expand on it all
that much yeah we didn't go off on a
bunch of different tangents I guess we
were trying to and I and I was more
stringent about editing them then
because you know we didn't have a video
component at that time and I was usually
just like you know putting in photos
although I do remember like getting mad
at you because sometimes you
off on tangents and be like goddamnit I
didn't have any pictures of that see
they had to go in like five pictures of
like [ __ ] that you went off yeah well
back on those days we weren't sure if
the videos if they went or if they were
over an hour if we you know maybe would
like lose out and the algorithms or
people wouldn't subscribe or they
wouldn't sit around because they'd be
like 400 hour that's flashes too long he
had I mean anyone because we were kind
of coming out of a time when we believe
that a shorter video got more hits and a
channel like that got more subscribers
and you actually could get it monetized
and I think maybe that's the way it was
a long time ago maybe like in 2012
maybe 2010 but you know yeah maybe there
was that window whatever was it had a DD
yeah remember remember how some of those
little some of those little clickbait
channels so I could had millions and
millions of views and they were making
all kinds of money and it was there
basically just stealing the best of
other people's material yeah that little
[ __ ] that came off of cell phones and
[ __ ] you know I mean in compilations of
motorcycle wrecks and some of those
dudes were making an incredible money
yeah and you know you look at the views
they would get like [ __ ] 64 million
views or whatever you like what the [ __ ]
and it's like a ten minute video yeah I
felt like for a long time like between
ten and fifteen minutes seemed like the
sweet spot although it depends on what
it is it's like honestly I don't listen
to a lot of other podcasts um you know I
will if I'm like researching a topic or
you know researching a case or whatever
but what I generally do because I don't
wear myself out enough and I have to be
doing like two or three things at once
or else I don't feel productive so I'll
be doing one thing on this computer and
then I'll have like a podcast about like
our next topic for like next week's show
going on this computer so I can have it
like playing in the background so I can
like get some osmosis information you
know what I mean so I like it when the
videos are long because I'm usually
working on something over here yeah and
then you know so I can just like listen
to it and get all into it and stuff so
it does seem like you know
shows like last podcast on the left and
all this other kind of stuff they
usually do like two or three parts
things about like a serial killer like
said they did one on Ed Gein and I think
it was three parts and it ended up being
I mean each part was like between one
and two hours yeah so that was like a
four hour show which is about what we
did I think I think we did a three or
four hour thing about Ed Gein so they
did about the same thing yeah I always
wanted to do like long format stuff yes
I wanted to be I have like a talk show
yeah with guests and everything but men
it's it's so technologically unwieldly
every time we had guests it was a real
pain in the ass to make sure Billy was
right and that the audio worked and it
was good on their head like Skype would
keep like cramping out and it's just
kind of like I would use the audio at
some points it it's like it was just
such a giant pain yeah and if you had a
guest on that people you know maybe
didn't like then all of a sudden [ __ ]
trolls ended up [ __ ] come to your
account yet on I mean it's just yeah I
mean I did like when we had guests on
you had a few on we usually with angry
gay Pope on with Steve Mara and stuff
but yeah we had the guy from summer wind
but yes those guys are pretty safe but
you know yeah a GPU not I mean you can
get the [ __ ] of Scientologists on your
[ __ ] case I was actually surprised
that we didn't get the scientist we
didn't I guess we didn't [ __ ] you
know I mean we did not call enough well
they well he's a lot more famous yeah so
it's like yeah but wait I don't think I
got any like weird Scientology comments
or our most divisive our most divisive
show was our biggest show and that was
about the war the word which I never
would have thought that in a million
years that that would have been the show
that gets the most abusive comments on
it if we don't like I said I general oh
we didn't [ __ ] we did yes and yes
suck the [ __ ] you know I mean I'm not
gonna suck the Warrens guy I don't
believe he really not now cuz they're
both dead yeah I still don't believe I
don't believe all their cases were legit
and I think they exaggerated some stuff
some stuff was real but I don't think at
all he fought a [ __ ] werewolf yeah
that's what he claimed he fought a
[ __ ] where and it's just say that was
from that it was another era
it was the Golden Age of [ __ ] Geraldo
yeah the Geraldo show and the [ __ ] of
daytime talk shows and and and I still
love that [ __ ] the stupider the better
yeah Edie now I can't really stomach it
I'd knew how to play that game
he gave TV talk shows what they wanted
yeah and they didn't necessarily want
the truth well obviously because that's
no fun is it yeah it's no fun no but I
think there were a couple cases they
were involved in that were legit what
I'm sure they kind of exaggerated a lot
of it they were involved in the unfilled
case they got into that one uninvited I
know that was a real case but the other
people that were there it was like they
were they were like who these people
that's the thing in me and I feel like
they made the hole at the contouring to
which was about Enfield and kind of
inserted them in like they were like the
main investigators in the case and
according to the people that actually
investigated that that was not there
like they did show up but nobody asked
them - yeah from what I heard they
showed up and they were there for maybe
a day yeah they were just there for one
day and she showed up on the doors like
hey heard you had a yeah and they were
there for a day and evidently [ __ ]
Edie [ __ ] ran around the place
[ __ ] talking about demons didn't see
anything and then left yeah cuz I would
imagine and now there's like a whole
movie franchise yeah they're just like
yeah they were totally in on that [ __ ]
everybody that were some was like you
know guy Lyon Playfair Morris chorus
like all the people that were there like
for the whole [ __ ] year and a half
yeah we're like yeah they didn't do any
of that stuff yeah evidently you know
like guy Playfair was like yeah I heard
that somebody came by that was yeah
somebody was in America the kids said
they saw somebody a strange man and then
he left
well it's like I don't even need to like
turn up anywhere they probably didn't
even need to pay the airfare to go all
the way over there to turn up and just
be like why don't they just send two
phone calls like guess what it's demons
by yeah that's rush all they had to do
and this head was drifting you know I
mean and I don't think he believed that
was a real case you know I mean because
he fakes so much [ __ ] I don't even think
he thought that was real yeah so he
showed up just to say he was there and
then he went back to United States to
tell whatever story
to tell Sookie get back on Geraldo yeah
and probably he showed up he probably
disturbed Janet so much that the
phenomena stops so she could look at him
she's like what because whenever anybody
showed up if I can mammoth or [ __ ]
you know if anything disturbed the scene
it would die down for a few hours
it was slow to come back but that's
probably what happened it showed up and
this just stop and head says all here's
another fake case yeah I'm here demon
demon bow gotta go call [ __ ] Geraldo
haven't got a fight by next got a real
fight that werewolf werewolf I gotta get
on Sally Jessy Raphael and then once all
this just lying I'll tell him what I did
here and I don't had that [ __ ] slowed
down you know I mean it hung out for
awhile me 3 or 4 days he probably saw
some pretty cool phenomenon but you know
what though I mean chances are he'd have
been scared shitless although I don't
know he said if poltergeists could scare
the [ __ ] out of you he claimed to seen
other ones like literally and I just
said oh it's just a poltergeist it's
gonna be uh it [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
out of you said one time I think he
remember him saying that I think I saw
that clip of that interview yeah I think
he had seen some paranormal stuff but I
think yeah it's a dream I faked a lot of
[ __ ] and I think we said that on the
warrant show it's like I'm not saying
that every single thing that they were
involved in was fake I don't think that
no I think some of it was real but I
think it almost all of it was
exaggerated even what was real yeah even
if it was real because I mean there were
like pretty legit sources that said [ __ ]
like you know later on like there was
really scary [ __ ] going on her
paranormal [ __ ] going on in the case but
then like when the Warrens investigated
and someone was writing a book about it
they're like well add this that and the
other thing like to make the book scary
so it was well um didn't that weren't
they involved in the what was that case
where the people said they got raped by
invisible pigs great by a visible with
any swirls
I don't remember that one I kind of feel
like that was I don't remember if we did
a [ __ ] or not [ __ ] sorry those are a
little yeah people mister Gramm should
know better they're talking about her
boobs
the UH just kidding that's another
channel we go it's a good idea anyway
anyway what I was trying to say and I
threw myself off off off the track yeah
like last time I was talking about the
caucus or yeah and you just like they
haven't heard the caucus or sorry caucus
or the car yeah but that's gonna be on
the mat nation well the patrons have
seen it because it went up for the
patrons this morning but it doesn't go
up til to everybody until tomorrow
yeah morning the caucus or there's a
movie you can see you'll see you know on
xbox you don't read it it it's it's [ __ ]
but it's got a caucus or in it well now
you just made everybody wanna watch it
what was it called dust rider that dust
Walker dust Walker yeah
it's an Australian movie they let me
down usually it started out good but
then yeah um now we talk about it you
guys we'll see you tomorrow what
speaking of caucus or apparently there's
a movie out there called velociter and
yeah I really need to see that priest in
half half dinosaur half velociraptor
hold on I was gonna say something maybe
something out here knows with this and
there was one of them I think it was on
maybe like a wasn't Phil Donahue was
that his name yeah O'Donoghue yeah
that's right it's been so long yeah
that's old school his old school [ __ ] I
think we see throwing Phil Donahue or
like on Sally Jessy Raphael it might
have been what's his name what's that
[ __ ] name Geraldo rather Maury people
there was some yeah maybe Maury pons
that might have been might have been
more I don't know
before this is before those two before
Montel Ricki
anyway somebody had a hat I had a pretty
much a whole house of women honest guess
okay he was a paranormal investigator
and they just kept hearing
grunting and heavy breathing and one
girl woke up in the from in the daytime
woke up she was fell asleep and saw like
a shadowy figure of a dude kneeling at
the [ __ ] bed at her bed looking at
her just [ __ ] just going at it man
just beaten off and he vent any faded
away and then there was like they kept
reporting like having their [ __ ]
titties grabbed and their asses grabbed
in the shower and they could hear a
man's voice and panting and you know gee
pervert [ __ ] and that was it
there was no plot to it or anything and
they didn't say much and they looked
[ __ ] terrified and they didn't have
really the money to get that get get out
of there well yeah and it was like only
like maybe like a teenage boy and maybe
like a little kid and I don't there
weren't any men in the house it was all
women I think there must have been about
six of them and it turns out the
investigator had a bunch of photos from
guys that had something to do with the
house it was had to do with the
apartment it was I think it was an
apartment so you guys might remember man
I can't find it again and I haven't seen
a reference sounds awfully familiar
though the guy had done an investigation
I think it was on an apartment that had
like a couple of bungalows in it you
know I mean like two or three houses
connected yeah and he did like a blind
ID like the cops would do and they all
identified as like the prior [ __ ]
property manager as the guy that they
keep seeing and he had died of like a
heart attack about four or five years
before yeah he's still being a skis and
I have a dad yeah and I dammit and then
he lived on the property before he died
he lived in one of those apart with my
luck if I ever got haunted it would be a
dude like that yeah and evidently and if
I remember correctly I mean this was man
30 30 something years ago he had like a
history of sex offenses - yeah I can't
even back on his life you know I mean he
was an old guy when he died in 60s or
something gross but if anybody knows
that case man leave a comment in the
bottom I only saw it on that one show
daytime talk show never saw it again
but it was after Mammoth Mountain and
they saw I already had experience myself
and looking at them women's faces I
could tell that that it was probably
true yeah that would be kind of the
worst yeah
they looked like the head slept in a
long time they looked for [ __ ]
mortified to like they were [ __ ]
super barest he didn't want to talk
about it well yeah I'll blame him have
ok with it was a molesters a Chester the
molester ghost yeah and what is it with
he was you said he was like the
apartment manager the property manager
like that because I feel like ok so I
listen to like mr. nightmare sometimes I
probably manager the owner one of the
two because I think he lived on prop
yeah but I'm trying to like you know
relax and stuff I like to listen like
those scary stories and a lot of them
are true like true stories that people
were all allegedly true that people have
submitted that he can read and he's he's
done ones where like this the person is
like landlord or some [ __ ] like that'll
be like coming in their house and like
sniffing their panties and [ __ ] like
that when they're out it's like what
what the [ __ ] he was one of those and
everybody died and he is that's very
widespread astral forces in the his
force ghost is [ __ ] in there in India
in the other dimension wasting your
afterlife you fight you die you find out
that I got me a ghost and that's all you
do with it yeah he's a that's all you do
where they didn't have a higher
spiritual [ __ ] vision in life man if
I died and found out that leg ghosts are
real and I could be a ghost and I could
like run around haunt and [ __ ] and
everything I do all kind of fun that's
what that's what [ __ ] she's gonna go
around like jerking off watching people
that's much nemesis Agha's gonna do wow
that's just Eva sigalas can do and we
caught it we Mandy Annie but he called
it poo nanny nanny yeah no nanny he
called it was like we were doing the
show about it I was like I didn't want
to say that lyrics it was just like so
cringe-worthy but it's like what you
know you know what like we were mean to
Steven Seagal like on the show me more
than you probably
and so when he dies he's gonna haunt me
and he's gonna do that [ __ ] and he's
gonna like come up and like say punani
and many years out alcohol
god damn it Steve you totally simply
something I would do as a ghost
what a dick it's like Russian slave
girls with him where every graduate the
afterlife everything else you want
that's it this was a fun one today even
though like I'm - I'm still like kind of
hungover ready - gnarly hungover I just
really really tired really sleepy and I
even like slept in this morning this is
Saturday morning is the only morning
that I allow myself just sleep in it and
even so like you still woke me up at 70
like you go over a walk this morning and
I was like no I'll take a nap Lee I
thought it was still the weekday no yeah
no I was wanting to go for a walk
actually we can go we can go later after
I get show uploaded okay all right so uh
we'll have a good rest you Saturday and
we'll talk to you again tomorrow